hey guys so what is the difference
between successful people and
unsuccessful people habits daily habits
we're creatures of habit and your habits
influence your whole life and to change
your life you need to change your habits
successful people are just normal people
with good daily habits and you need to
start to break your bad habits to be
successful so in this video that's what
we're gonna look at we're gonna look at
the seven bad habits that you need to
stop to be successful let's get to it
[Music]
mistakes make you strong
stop wasting time everybody is the same
we all get a 24 hour a day nobody gets
more it doesn't matter who you are you
can always get more money but you can
never get more time so what are you
doing with your time the time you have
is your life so if you waste your time
you're wasting your life so to use your
time more effectively you need a good
balance in your daily routine are you
playing too much games every day or
watching too many TV series or spending
your time on the wrong kind of people
you got to start to use your time more
effectively to reach your goals the more
you waste your time the longer it will
take you to reach your goals
quit listening to negative people I mean
it's always good to get good advice good
quality advice from the right people but
stop wasting your time on toxic people
that is always negative Albert Einstein
said stay away from negative people
because they have a problem for every
solution now I agree of him because you
can never win an argument or a
conversation with a negative person
because they only hear what they want to
hear and they listen only to respond you
gotta walk this life of the right kind
of people you walk with the wise to
become wise or you hang out with fools
and become a fool and suffer for it so
ignore negative people but listen to
wise people that speak the truth and I
will stand by you no matter what
gotta stop going for quick fixes a lot
of people want to be successful but they
don't want to put in the work but true
success requires sacrifice it requires
commitment and it requires you to be
consistent over a long period of time
there are no shortcuts to any place
worth going in his life the things in
life that matters the most
take heart where can you take
consistency just like relationships it
takes time to really get to know a
person and to build a strong
relationship of trust you know people
who always look for quick fixes in life
never really improve their character
because it is the journey that matters
most not the destination it is the
journey that teaches us to overcome
obstacles to stand up if we fall it is
the journey towards our goals that
teaches us to become better
stop making excuses stop playing the
victim because all of us who live in
this world go through tough times life
is always a series of ups and downs
successful people they don't make
excuses all the time they put their head
down and they work for their goals if
you got in the habit of always making
excuses and playing the victim then
you're actually a victim of your own
reality you gotta stop making excuses
and feeling sorry for yourself because
if you continue on this road you'll get
stuck in a life if you get stuck nothing
will change so stop making excuses and
start making changes make things happen
yeah I get it a lot of things in this
world is unfair not everything is always
equal but you can either sit and
complain about it or you can stand up
and you can fight for your dreams for
the goals that you want to achieve so
stop blaming other people because you
are in charge of making your own
decisions you know for some people
they've been doing this for a long time
the habit is so strong that they lie to
themselves they've created fake images
of themselves in their mind and it is
not based on reality and then when they
experience the consequences of their own
decisions and actions they blame other
people for their own mistakes and then
they wonder why they can't build good
relationships with other people why
don't people like them why do people
avoid them if you always blame other
people for your mistakes
of course you're pushing them away and
they won't support you in anything so
man up or woman up and take
responsibility for your own actions
stop doing things halfway whatever you
do finish it go into something fully all
in or get all out there is no halfway
gotta give it everything you got
100% my mom always drilled this into me
while I was growing up Daniel you should
do something you either give it
everything you got or leave it and don't
give up we all fail we all fall but
successful people they don't stay down
they get up they continue they fight
every time they fall they get up they
don't change their goal they just change
their plan
don't let fear control your life fear is
one of the worst enemies a person can
have fear of being unsuccessful fear of
failing fear of the unknown fear of
change and the fear of not being good
enough you gotta face your fear if you
don't face your fear it will become your
limit but only if you face it only then
can you reach your full potential don't
be lazy lazy people lazy people would
achieve very little in life because what
you sow you will reap if you put in
nothing you will get nothing you have to
have goals in your life and then work
for them get your goals and then plan
for the future you know a lot of people
just accept their present situation so
they get in their comfort zones and they
stay there but if you just stay there
and you do the same thing every day day
after day you will get stuck in life and
it will become boring and a lot of
people get depressed and they don't
understand why it is good to dream about
your goals every night when you go to
bed and you dream about the goal is when
achieve in life is good but nothing will
happen if you don't actually work for it
some people will always only dream about
success while other people stand up
early in the morning to actually work
for it to make it happen so which one
are you if you want to start by
improving yourself and check out this
playlist it'll help you out and I'll see
you there
cheers guys